so so today we're looking at the ethics
of care and this is a relatively new
moral theory in certain respects some
parts of it or not but the way it's put
together as a whole and the different
emphases that it has is relatively new
and it gets started and you can say
really with feminist moral theory coming
out of the 1960s and 1970s and starts to
take real the term of the shape of the
1980s and 1990s which for us is already
historical one of the things you notice
when you're reading these these two
articles that they say Virginia helm and
Rosemarie Tom articles is their writing
about all these things that have to be
done and feminist transformations and
moral theory but they're writing about
it 20 years ago so actually a little bit
more than 20 years health articles from
Maggie this is before a body were born
and I brought this up to the last class
you know dude if feminism is in large
part about taking women's concerns and
experiences into account fully into
account are they the same for your
generation as they were say for your
parents generation
think about some of the changes of
advances your women in class does
anybody ever call you Colette did you
ever heard that term probably curtain
right 40 years ago all of you would have
been poets because you would have been
marked as unusual by being a woman in a
college classroom nowadays there's
actually more female college students
and there are male college students in
your generation there are more women in
college and graduation rates are higher
some things have changed in some
respects I'm not gonna actually ask for
a show of hands but think about how many
of you would describe yourself as cut us
some quarters that's a dirty word and
when I asked the last class which is the
last class by the way is mostly women
than the 8 o'clock session I asked them
so what is kinda doesn't mean to you and
you get about five different answers
because it's changed its meaning over
over time if you have to boil it down to
the common thing that they all share I
suppose it would be that they they all
say that you know what's been left out
of the picture at all too long as
women's experiences and concerns and
this was going on a moral theory you
know who actually wrote a lot of moral
theory that we've been reading that
right yeah
okay here's normal and you want sense
what is that
okay then they have more opportunities
to do so too right
I mean the educational institutions were
once dominated by men
politics was dominated by men still is
to some extent the economy so a lot of
these thinkers you know some of these
singers too by the way are coming out of
the situations where women are radically
excluded from Aristotle writing in
ancient Athens play them too in ancient
Athens except for you know women working
in the marketplace processes and a few
slaves women were in the house and that
was it it was very strictly separate so
you know Socrates is unusual that here
he talks about how to learn from women
when I was the product of their culture
did it have to be that way
no so you know Aristotle says a lot of
things in nowadays you look at and say
wow that's really crazy to say that but
if you look at his culture I think it
helps you to understand that does that
make it okay okay well you know he just
didn't know any better a lot of things
that matter to women probably should
matter to them to get left out of the
picture as a result yeah look at
lost there are some within philosophers
in ancient times but they were the
exceptions and for instance the cynic
school there was a guy practice and it
was one of the teachers yeah his wife
was a cynic - it's really bad
blinking on her name the reason why she
was the philosopher because her father
made a deliberate effort to bring her on
different than the other women as a
philosopher it was understood that
philosophies of male concern so these
two married and Linda's aesthetics which
basically meant you know living very
smart and lifestyles Rene Descartes you
may remember from your control class one
of the people who spurred well there are
two women who were very important in the
spur in his life one gaining a job Queen
Christina of Sweden
she brought a bunch of Sweden which I
was like a superpower to the court
philosophers but he also had a
correspondence with the Christmas
Princess Elizabeth and that led take her
to write one of the few pieces arguably
ethics that he did the treaty some
passions in the soul and the reason why
he did it is if she spurred his thinking
but do we know a lot about her other
than that not really because you know
again it was normal not to care too much
about women's contributions there have
been some really important women
philosophers in the twentieth century
Simone they arrived
I was Murdoch these are all people
before the feminist revolution is really
getting underway in the 60s and 70s
making contributions a lot of stuff get
left out or downplayed as a result of
nine women involvement the processes of
if you want to think about the ethics of
care it has to do with with these sorts
of things we've talked about some of
these in this class have like
relationships every time that I asked
you what are the most important things
to you what are the things you find make
your life valuable one of the things
you're worried about losing what are
your good you guys bring up the
relationships with friends right
a lot of moral theories don't recognize
relationships individual relationships
as goods that are not just reducible to
the people involved the ethics of care
stresses relationships stresses the
importance of them so if you have to
choose between two courses of action one
of which is going to promote or support
for continued relationships and the
other one's going to break them down and
other things are equal you should choose
the one that supports relationships
maybe even if it's between pleasure
would be more pleasant for you than
maintaining your relationship yeah I
think some care would saying maintain
the relationship you know are your
friends always pleasant to be with what
about your family
you pick your friends and you can't pick
your family right but should you should
you keep those relationships up it may
not even hurt yourself screw that
do people do that don't they that's a
that's a choice that you make we realize
to continue a relationship to foster to
see it as it's valuable
what about their relationship
relationship is screwed up
do you just cut and run or do you say we
got to fix this yeah things to care
would say it's very important to fix
broken relationships that's a good that
might be more valuable than money
prestige pleasure even getting to do
your own thing success relationships are
another thing that ethics of care
stresses emotions and we've talked a
little bit about emotions over the
course of the semester we're going to
talk about the more we need to Aristotle
traditionally if you think about
traditional gender roles who's more
emotional you know with traditional why
is there any reason
first of all you think it's actually
true the women are I think you're right
about that yeah also we portrayed
different kinds of emotions that's what
I think people forget they're all
emotions yeah it's just what type of
emotions are you portrayed because when
we think emotional we're thinking
sensitive but there's differences yes if
you have to pick one emotion that men
are allowed to express generally not
just necessarily in our society and you
know battlefield that's a good place to
show anger in the marketplace you're
right that's an emotion but you know men
and women feel that the entire range of
other emotions you know ranging from
fairly neutral ones like surprise to
very negative ones like disgust hatred
certain forms of sadness to very
positive ones like joy but you're right
in a lot of societies the way that we
understand gender makes it easier it
gives women the permission you might say
to express things that men can but also
women sometimes are allowed to express
other things in them can write are men
and women who are angry perceive the
same way there is there are certain
inhibition
limiting certain pressures right the
woman is a angry she's seen us as a more
dangerous than the man who's angry
pretty unlikely right maybe whose clock
you guys the crystal cracks a lot of
women in prison when most states will
actually have a place that's called
global minutes prison because that they
don't they don't need a whole bunch of
yeah some of the motions traditionally
the way in which we feel and express and
Ally emotions has been very much
dependent on gender and emotions have
been for for a large part pushed out of
philosophy and pushed out of that yes if
you want to figure out what you want to
do you want to put your emotions aside
put your feelings aside
the fact that you love somebody else
might need you to be you know less that
less than impartial might lead you to
favor them and that would be a bad thing
wouldn't it we severe utilitarian or a
conscience now would that necessarily be
a bad thing from other ethical
perspectives can you think of any ethics
other than the ethics of care that say
it's important to have certain feelings
I think about certain moral codes or
certain moral ideals any now the whole
theory think of the Sermon on the Mount
after this Jesus guy's walking around
saying things like love your enemies
what was the function to do and you know
we don't mean the emotional actions but
that's not actually because it also says
if your anger is your brother
you'll be liable to the judgment the
peacemaker is almost other stuff that
has to do with kind of affective or
emotional stances virtue ethics also
thinks that that your emotions really
matter it's it's not whether you feel it
or not do you feel them in the right way
at the right time
do you act on them the right way but our
emotions are can be a guide for our
behavior a lot of moral theories
excluded that the ethics of care says we
should actually rely on our emotions
provided it's not enough every emotion
so if I hate people that doesn't mean
that to do it they will have a great
good reason to keep people but our
emotions are often a good guide for how
we want to behave in certain emotions
really cultivating good what do you see
as a positive emotions in your life what
do you want
what do ya the sense of maybe even
admiration accomplish great things
certainly respect treating it has a
person what else
respect is not we all want to be loved
we all not even necessarily a lot of
with the big Valentine's Day hard stuff
but we all want to be we don't want
people to feel duty for it's a
suspension of towards us to like us
there's a deep-seated need within all of
us even the harmful targeted person to
actually be loved by somebody when I was
teaching in the prison indiana state
prison they were all these cats all over
the place and the reason that those cats
were there were prisoners adopted them
and these cats would be used in itemize
it was humane society so it's good for
the cancer get killed it's good for the
guys because the guys now have a pets
and it's good for the prison overall
because it gives something they can take
away from
they really care about so it helps keep
them quiet if they screw up the cat cats
taking rats
and if they work a prism job and make up
to like 35 cents an hour and some of the
guys actually would have a prison job 40
hours a week to pay for the cat food cat
litter cats what I was really struck by
was how loving a lot of these guys were
in describing the cat's work towards
their own cats or towards other people's
cats so you can see these hardened guys
who you know a lot of them work out all
the time huge guys tattoos you know all
over their bodies you know all sorts of
weird you know facial hair forever
another because they all make a
statement in prison khakis picking up
the cat and pep-talking those two which
looks kind of maybe tempted say oh these
guys are just marvelous well they're not
because if you if you take them out of
that context they're they're you know
dangerous guys fight with each other in
regards but for a lot of these guys
what's really great about those cats
it's the first thing that they're able
to log and take care of and that
experience helps to change them all the
time it's sort of like an apprenticeship
becoming more and more
teamate so sweet
not every moral theory could see that as
important right the ethics of care would
see that is something absolutely central
we shouldn't if you're following the
other care we should have those kind of
policies in place to try to change
people for the better that love them
experience these positive emotions to
form attachments responsibilities
another thing that's that's Germania
ethics of care
very often when we think about you guys
may be against this in this class it's
almost like if to take yourself out of
the picture and take other real people
out of the picture we think about
utilitarianism is that sound about right
this is not the case for everything
right we talked about loss loss hate
real relationships matter real context
he wasn't big on emotions but he did say
you know we actually have these duties
that we sense in real context of in
those situations and the ethics of care
says that what matters more is persons
than principles okay this isn't
completely immediately there's a type of
philosophy of personalism which actually
stresses this as well to be a
personalist but historically would have
took to bring these issues to the fore
was the feminist revolution and this
attention to you know bringing women's
voices back into into philosophy and to
stress the importance of these things
could could you know could this have all
been realized without having probably it
didn't happen that by the way that
happened
it took women saying it is stuff matters
pay attention to it you know knocking
off the stuff that's keeping you from
paying attention to it for it to
actually change now that this piece
bye-bye torn part what she's doing is is
explaining the ethics of care which is
coming in part of Carol Gilligan's work
and then she's looking at some
criticisms so that's what we're going to
do today and you can think to yourself
oh those good criticisms or bad
criticisms so first let's get kind of a
handle on and why Gilligan came up with
this epic of care there's there's two
main things that that Tom talks about
one of them has to do with oil
development or anything familiar with
this Kohlberg scale of development in
the past were sociology class where you
saw it somewhere else
it's got Kohlberg who actually his work
came out of working in prisons by the
way he came up with this scale levels in
a one through six of moral development
at the very low level your concern
mainly just with you know an eagle
perspective punishment reward that's
that's it that's all you care about
thinking about infants right infants are
not particularly the world beings
two-year-old children either baby so
it's very selfish out there and they can
do on such things but they also have
this attitude what's mine is mine
what's yours is mine if you don't like
it I'm going to yell and kick scream and
how do you get them to behave reward
them and punish them because that's
about all they know but after a while
they start to you know get to higher
levels they start to you know they get
to the point where they care about what
other people
think and feel so they want to be a good
boy or good girl
because I'm one of the peoples of that
you that's better than just you know I'm
going to punish you for reward you know
you're not gonna like the pain that I
give you to the wrong thing that's
that's a higher level to be motivated by
I one of the people who like me I want
to be able to be relationship with them
and then we can get higher and higher
except recognizing each other's rights
you know in starts saying I'm gonna
treat you like this because I want you
to treat me this way
and eventually we can get to the point
where we recognize abstract principles
we go through the social contract stage
as well for Kohlberg that eventually get
to the basic so Gilligan was a student
of kober's
and she was looking at men and women and
the way that they carry off the world
reasoning that's what Kohlberg measures
that scene he gets people testing says
here's a moral dilemma for you how would
you solve this moral dilemma and why
would you do this way
sort of like what I do with you in the
application science right then the
application assignments it's not just
finding that you know what should you do
it's also being able to explain well
from this perspective we would do this
here's why this is the case so they do
these tests and then they locate people
at these different models they look at
the way in which they you carry on
always so you know if the person is
saying well this person should do this
just so they don't get in trouble
they're probably a little up if they say
you know it's not right that they do
this because what if everyone else to
that
they're higher when killing an observed
is that men and women don't always
approach these things the same way at
least some question society women much
more often would frame things in terms
of relationships for framing because the
preservation of the relationship or the
relationship involves certain duties or
responsibilities towards each other they
would bring out how people would feel so
doing something like doing something bad
might be wrong not just because it harms
another person or you know the damages
their interest but because it means that
the feel of that and they were much more
interested in talking about the real
people involved than just using abstract
principles now the problem is from a
Kohlberg scale perspective that would
place women about a big way so that
would mean that women at least the women
who were you know falling into this sort
of typical pattern would be less morally
developed that men who were reasoning in
a social contract or country and get
them to noted that at least in our
society if you ask about moral matters
quite often men frame things in terms
she called the Justice perspective they
talk in terms of rights you know
competition coming to agreements with
each other
fairness that sort of thing women quite
often talk in terms of the care
perspective the relationships emotions
caring for other people taking care of
people so does that mean that that man
can you know reach a higher level
because of their perspective that women
can that's the case then women would be
condemned to always be less or more
ladies
and so what Gilligan is saying is this
Kohlberg level is not really measuring
human it's measuring typically male so
we need another scale for measuring
women's development or typically females
because some management can have more
typically female attitude towards these
and some women have a more typically
they left right there's so many who care
about anybody else they're gonna protect
their rights you know achieve their
interests for everybody else all right
there's something like that
and there's some men who are you know
very interested in relationships and
caring and that's - so what would
another scale look like well Gilligan
talks in terms of stages as well so the
first stage needs to be self-centered
frame things in terms of what South
the second stage for women or for this
typically female way of looking at
things is to think about other people
and their wants their needs their
desires their interests but at the
exclusion of this topic once all and now
think about that for a moment there's
evidence for the typical or
stereotypical female and relating to
other people to put their own needs
ahead of one's own and to sacrifice
themselves do you think
think about how many ponds have like
worked it worked it worked almost
painlessly so they're kids
women in general get a lot of
recognition or respected where they use
or some sort of reciprocity for doing
the nurturing the caring of taking care
of people there's a lot of a kind of
uncompensated luck if you're willing to
care for other people can you find
yourself very easily caught in a
situation where there's an animal where
the other person's needs come to
predominate and yours
well if she's behind her needs are gonna
be taken care she's gonna subordinated
her own desires wishes aspirations to
taking care of this guy he might
benchmark based on what you're saying
what was said earlier like how a lot of
mothers like they take different jobs so
they can take care of their kids or even
wound up staying at home yeah I think
even to this day like well there's like
the potential you may have a 9 to 5 job
but when they come home they're still
stuck feeling like the house stories
yeah there's them and you don't most of
us don't really value that like the only
time I personally realizes every now
that one like you know my parents go on
a vacation and I'm stuck doing
everything in the house I'm like wow I'm
like you do a lot yeah that's what I
realize
and then I forget about it all over you
no problem somebody could probably
relate to that situation I think my mom
does I don't think it's about like it's
like sometimes we don't realize that
they happy you know and we don't give it
to them and how they because I think
you're right and it is different you
talked about it being different in
different situations it's different
between the generations two things are a
bit more equal for your generation and
dividing Federation and they were for me
I'm just like really involved in my life
and her mom was just not involved in her
life so then once that
because I mean I guess she didn't have
very nurturing parents yeah but I guess
that's you can go both ways like you
could have parents aren't nurturing and
then you can become like a real
energetic or even have parents have been
really enriched for you and you could be
the same - you're kidding because I
guess yeah I think you're right welcome
back we are a product of those who we
are persons is not some abstract link a
context at the beginning of the semester
we're caught up in our own stories and
our stories are in the market Park who
else is in our stories if you had a
nurturing parents that's part of your
story and that allows you different ways
to experience a complete I actually grew
up like my dad was born in 1840 woman if
I ever did something like clean my mom
is like a successful lawyer and he is
obedient you hear about how she is never
home and like but anyway but I think
that mothers have that role and they
founds that role only because I think
it's nature I think that that reaction
is natural because the easy way
completely
and he somebody who has to be
responsible for like nurturing it and
making sure it survives so you think and
that's something that the ethics of care
talks about as well places a premium on
care and care for children especially
the baby doesn't just receive food they
did these experiments they didn't mean
to do these experiments back in the
1950s there was very German conscious
back then so they took these these
children in orphanages and they didn't
pick them up much they didn't handle
them
while the babies died and they were
being fed enough on their feet now
changed and all the other stuff they
weren't sick they just didn't try as it
turns out in order to develop properly
babies actually need to be touched need
affection they need shared gaze and
therefore the ranks that it all right
they need to be talked to they do need
showcase yeah that's part of the process
of the moment a child who doesn't have
these things if they survive as an
attachment
I guess and so I think it's interesting
since he's very like strength and like
old school and my mom's 10 years younger
than him and she's totally different
they're just like I know I have like
sleeping problems because I can't wear
that in my mind like yeah wired all the
time and like I really can't be healthy
for life needs to be engaged to be there
like in like 10 years of that they're
starting using such advanced technology
there was actually a proposal in The
Chronicle of Higher Education just this
week that says that your generation
needs to be taught how to pay attention
because I'm not quite sure that I buy
that we have to start thinking in terms
of attention literacy skills or
something like that the technology that
modifies our living I don't think I
think secure talked too much about that
per se but that's important we can would
you talk more about that later the
virtue ethics is a situation when
competitive so we talked about a stage
where the person is going for the
personal self center and then they
become very other center at the expense
of the self and that's an advance that's
better than just being so centered but
the best stage is to be at the place
where one can reconcile one's own needs
wants aspirations with taking care of
other people's lawns needs aspirations
recognizing that so Dan splett Gilligan
says female instead of just you know
going away from sort of egos I go to the
universal more or less conscient
perspective it goes from a self to other
to self and other relationship
perspective could you bring the two of
them together probably there's another
thing I want to talk about as well that
Gilligan brought up she talked Jesus
Freudian psychoanalytic what's called
object relational theory and
you're probably all trivia at this
complex yeah what she's interested in is
not that you know the male child wants
to kill the day and marry the mom or
maybe that's right
because that's actually not afraid to
say what do you would instinct what
she's getting from that is that in order
to become a self they have an identity
male children and dissociating from of
the monitor who is the source of
affection and nurturing and all that
yeah
identifying that the father was usually
out there traditionally in the workplace
you know has more prestige but is also
in some ways more out of touch with his
his emotional side and so in order to
become of me on that means you have to
separate from the emotional and become a
more rational competitive interested in
fairness rules that's what stuff what
happens for girls when they're developed
they they you know desire but the father
has to offer us or it was simple but
they don't disassociate from mother they
identified until they're forced out of
that might say somebody comes along and
says hey we got to break these
associations with your your girlhood
friends you're too close to them this is
holding you back
that sort of thing and they experience
that as a loss and what she talks about
women in in trouble with is developing a
sense of self apart from other people
so that the danger for women is finding
another person you know it's a romantic
relationship with a man and seeing
themselves as the caretaker the support
system in a man and that is being a
personal the problem that the boys and
that men end up having had given this
theory is with developing the
possibility of intimacy that closeness
that being in touch with one's emotional
Society will share that so both sexes
ended up becoming stunted because of
this so an ethics of care would be
trying to would be advocating things
that would bridge that yeah so if it's a
moral theory
moral theories you tell us how we ought
to act what kind of people we ought to
be under decide difficult cases this
moral theory would be saying these are
the things that really counts when
you're trying to figure out what the
right thing to do is figure out what
would actually nurture other people what
would sustain relationships
what would allow people's emotions to
play a role now there's some criticisms
the other character we're not going to
go to all of these let's look at a few
of this what she's contrasting to the
care perspective is what she calls the
justice respect so we've looked at some
justice perspective moral theories
to myself there are certain things that
are right things that are wrong certain
things that are Affairs or the things
that are unfair my rules for things
rather than just focusing on
relationships that may not actually have
rules governing them so much as you know
a sense of who the other person is and
what their needs are to justice and care
intersect where they totally Center for
each other it sounds when you read
Gilligan or you read some of these other
ethics of care of people like you've got
you know care over here and justice over
here and they got nothing to do with
each other but could that really be the
case maybe there are actually you know
more like the interpenetrating each
other so in order to be in order to
actually do justice to justice you know
a kind of a pond you would have to be
caring or in order to be adequately
caring you would actually have to worry
to some extent about fairness or justice
so some examples that Tom uses are
things like this you have a personal
relationship with another person
some of you may have been in this
already and you become the caregiver the
person who's always giving to the other
person taking care of them concerned
with them and they're primarily just the
recipients what's gets adults well it's
not say it's kids no brothers or sisters
adult relationships maybe with a friend
or boyfriend a drummer or even a parent
who's particularly needy if you're
constantly giving and you're not giving
you're not getting in return so your
needs aren't being recognized and
attended and cared for is that fair or
is that uh certainly unjust does it
exploited
yeah it was the right thing that I think
that you're doing the right thing
the roof is some relationships that are
necessarily when you have kids you're
going to find out that you're going to
if you're good way more but hopefully
your kids are taking care of
yeah so the there fairness wouldn't
insurance but if you have adult
relationships with two friends and you
can see cases like this where one friend
is constantly supporting the other tribe
that they're not getting anything that
seems so the fairness adjust with the
fairness or justice perspective and the
care perspective we fit together in that
way personal relationships also involve
becoming vulnerable to if you I mean
think about the damage that you could do
to your friends compared to people that
do you know stuff about your friends
weak spots if you are a bad person if
you you can easily exploit some of your
friends you might even exploit some of
the things that are best in them you
know it's a good sense of shame to do
that would be to be unjust to play-doh
their soul usually dark
corrupt within their their soul what
about when we screw things up you know
if we're the end relationships with
other people and we do care about are we
always caring
we were hurt their feelings I'm bad with
that I forget birthdays you know think
outside and we always properly grateful
do we say things that we didn't realize
you're gonna hurt the other person
what's our responsibility does yeah and
that's that's a matter of justice rather
than just a matter of caring then you
can see there was two sides it's like
sending cars I think this needs to be a
once instead of just I need to call my
friend yeah I need to just sometimes I
think it's better if you actually cuz my
kids I genuine desire to continue
as opposed to I need discretion then
you've seen the message as a tool of
your plate theory they're useful little
buddy I don't know if it's demands and
objects that we're talking about beauty
people's real persons or abstract
principles if you're saying I know we
haven't talked for a while I just want
to keep the line is communication well
there's also like like that hi there
mine
like usually find my mother's or my name
and I don't really feel like calling
people but it's not because I don't care
about them it's just I don't consider
that as valuable and somebody else made
you so so I'm doing it because I know
they'll feel good that I did it for them
but not because I actually wanted to
really you know my big problem is
actually is and some [ __ ] some of you
follow - you don't call somebody or
write to them for a while and then you
feel like you want to write and you feel
like well I got a really put aside some
time really
I think there's a difference between but
there's definitely a difference between
the one call someone and somebody then
there's a big difference of I should
call you know where truth is kind of
just like all right wanting to do it
just so they know like yeah what do you
want and need or kind of more of doing
it because you want to okay so we can
see that there's like three different
modes there's the wall should be good
there's the need because
because we actually it's the genuine
enjoy
that's an interesting set of
distinctions you guys are in effect
carrying out what they call
philosophical analysis
which is good only one with some of
these other aspects and criticisms so
justice and care intersecting about when
you've got relationships yeah it's not
just view and one other person but
there's a network of relationships then
fairness can come into it right
imagine you're a parent and you've got
three children one of your children
really really talented and that helmet
probably requires some some nurturing
and some scheduling things around to
cultivate let's say the child is a
really talented planets you start off
with the Suzuki method over there for
now your kids aren't quite so keen on
them maybe they do do you give more time
to deal together that's a question of
fairness right that's I mean if you're
carrying these as well you care about
all your kids equally but that doesn't
tell you exactly how that care should be
expressed maybe justice or some sense of
fairness has to come in and how you
distribute those things I know this is
kind of a different situation but my
grandmother on my dad's side had five
kids and my dad's twin get what the
disease called but it's where like your
Oh your head grows those are good yeah
my one kid has special needs
yeah and then my my aunt who's also not
office now had the spinal condition I've
hit upon she was on wheels
like so that like that's kind of the
same thing where you kind of put your
other kid or kids not in the background
but you kind of attend to the kids with
the needs a little more I know it's a
different situation because you have two
fits that help yeah well I think it's
it's it's a similar situation that
involves distribution of time tension
care coming from a different reason from
somebody's being quad and you know more
vulnerability rather than promotion
else's talents these two perspectives
care and justice but maybe care is not
as good at a moral perspective as
justice here's why they say that some
philosophers are perfectly willing to
regard care as beings from technically
feminine and they say they have
something to do the morality but they
see it less central to morality than
justice is or that way everything we go
against morality and here's how the
ethics of care says you should be a
certain kind of person you should be a
person who cares that's where it is to
be a good person a caring person tries
to foster or you know nurture or if
they're if they're bad to steer bad
relationships into good relationships
they respect other people's emotions
that
emotions into account what if you don't
think any person
well then from an ethics of care
perspective you would not be as been in
person so who is caring
now that makes it sound like in order to
be a good moral person you have to have
certain not just moral traits but
certain psychological traits like
picking your friends and yeah but you
just feel like it's like a poisonous
relationship what else to do yeah that's
that's a good question for the care
perspective that's one of the criticisms
that's made of it a little bit later on
and they they say if caring is such an
important thing and you're supposed to
foster relationships what about
relationships that are exploited in or
destructive or even to start holding you
back from developing the ethics of care
perspective would say well that's not a
good relationship and you don't try to
maintain that as a matter of fact
relationships sort of like traditional
male-female relationships where the man
is you know the rule giver the one who's
in charge
to support I guess one that would be a
bad relationship and the ethics of care
who wouldn't say that's a good thing to
continue it's hard to draw the line from
the perspective of ethics of care of
them again I think it's where justice
go back to the business welcome back to
that criticism so the ethics of care
seems to require people to be at a
certain source a certain psychological
need to be a caring person now let's
assume for the moment that there is a
sort of typical male attitude towards
the world of typical female think the
ethics of cures is the moral theory
about to use that made men are at a
disadvantage right because we're less
caring good more competitive what a
moral theory that like automatic that
puts one whole group atomicity had to be
a good wall theory though that's that's
a possible criticism of this I'm not
sure that that I buy that criticism good
exam yeah I mean let's let's compare
this to utilitarian perspective right
yeah it'd be almost as if you were to
say well you know utilitarians
utilitarianism says that you're not
supposed to make yourself central and
you know your pleasure pleasure but I
happen to be that kind of person there's
something wrong with utilitarianism
well no that means that there's
something wrong with me respective of
utilitarianism and if I accept as a
voluntary then that means I need to
learn how to be less self-centered and
to care more about the rest of you and
your pleasures and pains right so
there's your that's that's the problem
services now to go back to the issue of
exploitation or toxic brought toxic
relationships one of the problems with
the ethics of care is it doesn't seem
all that I'm well equipped to deal with
this or think about believe which which
occurs me and French are some things the
Broncos Trump frenemy all right
I think secure wouldn't say that's a
good relationship but how do you draw
the line is using that to say that that
relationship should be added or modified
the only way you could do that is if I
sort of taking then it starts to sound a
little bit like virtue ethics so we're
gonna see some similarities between this
the last thing that I want to get as far
as criticism the ethics of care because
it so the authors appear distinction to
male attitude towards things of justice
perspective and a female attitude
character spectrum right and it says
that traditionally historically men have
been over here movement them over here
and everybody should be like this
now if we're in a situation in which
society there have been in justices one
one gender is a tradition
one down position much more vulnerable I
think it's less the case now I think all
of you probably know somebody and just
trapped in an abusive relationship
they probably every one of us
what would the ethics of care say about
like when Thomas things much of the care
that women have traditionally provided
is to man who often don't reciprocate
and they just consume that that care so
that would harm women as a class not not
just as individuals but as an entire
class women who are in those sort of
situations then you could have the
reverse to or Manas the care of a woman
as long as now I'm super kidding when he
happens that is the person their needs
are being met
so they atrophy over time right so
they're not they're not developing as a
person because in order to develop as a
person you have to have certain needs
Matt they can't they lose the capacity
to be genuinely happy the other problem
is they begin to take on the perspective
of the one who's explained
they kind of see it as the new normal
the other danger that exists with this
is what about caring for somebody who's
a bad person there's not a storm of you
- harvey going to be and they she brings
up the example of the wife of the
Commandant at Treblinka one of the Nazi
death camps she was being nurturing and
supportive is that what an ethics of
care would say she ought to do probably
the role of the better she put poison in
the guy's teeth much of thing then you
know supported him through the whole
thing way to me actually the mother here
this may be one of the limits of the
ethics of care that it doesn't do well
in treating these these situations of
violence or harm to other people so
that's horrible
we'll leave wanna which we're time to
talk about